a deep rift in the republican party over
the january 6 attacks has once again
exploded into public view senate
minority leader mitch mcconnell has
rejected a republican party resolution
referring to those events on january 6
as quote legitimate political discourse
mcconnell says instead it was a quote
violent insurrection he also slammed the
rnc for censuring two republicans
investigating the attack nicole killian
has more now from washington
the highest ranking republican official
in the senate is making his stance clear
when it comes to the deadly january
sixth attack on the capitol it was a
violent insurrection for the purpose of
trying to prevent the peaceful transfer
of power tuesday senate minority leader
mitch mcconnell criticized the
republican national committee for
centering wyoming's liz cheney and
illinois adam kinzinger for serving on
the house select committee investigating
the insurrection
it was the language of the rnc
resolution to censure members of its own
party that struck a nerve stating that
cheney and kinzinger chose to join nancy
pelosi in a democrat-led persecution of
ordinary citizens who engaged in
legitimate political discourse but
members of the january 6 committee are
firing back ask the capitol police
officers
if
the people they interacted with were
engaged in legitimate
political discourse um it's just you
know at a human level it's just it's
just maddening
five people died after a pro-trump mob
breached the capitol building after
former president trump made repeated
false claims that the 2020 election was
stolen
rnc chair ronna mcdaniel claims the
party's position is being distorted and
wrote violence is not legitimate
political discourse whether in the u.s
capitol or in democrat-run cities across
the country the issue is
whether or not the rnc should be sort of
singling out
members of our party who may have
different views from the majority
that's not the job of the rnc
house minority leader kevin mccarthy has
dodged questions about the censure
resolution but conference chair elise
stefanik says the rnc has every right to
take any action now some house
republicans want cheney and kinzinger
expelled from the conference but she
told me that did not come up in their
meeting this week vlad
all right nicole killian for us on the
hill thank you very much